you know what it is what when you go
into that voting booth
and you press the button pull a lever
check the box tap the screen
yeah that that simple action is
the largest collective fu
to every single lie from the media yeah
to every single
for every single time the democrats told
you antifa didn't exist they were a myth
the violent
violence isn't real when you in your
area experienced it
when your shop was shut down by these
governors when your gym owner your
favorite gym had their owners arrested
pressing that button is sending that big
f you michael moore said it yeah
and you know what's funny michael moore
gave this this great speech
and boy was he wrong in the end but he
was right in the beginning where he said
that you know come november what was it
november 9th people are going to go in
the voting booth
and they're going to send the largest
collective fu to the establishment ever
recorded in history
and they'll enjoy it maybe maybe maybe
for the time because i i have a feeling
this like you you said democrats only
have have
uh what did they say every single
they've they've gone against every
single election that wasn't a landslide
and it was only two times yeah right two
landslides
trump 2020 landslide it's mine it's
gonna happen
michael moore said they'll send the
collective fu and they'll be happy
for a week maybe a month and then like
the people of the uk they'll realize
and then he goes off talking about how
bad it is and how they'll regret it yeah
until the economy
no no shut up i don't know this is
important okay go ahead he said the
people in the uk regretted voting brexit
except on december 13 2019
after brexit wasn't getting done for
three years
they sent another collective fu and
there were areas of the country in the
uk that hadn't voted conservative in 90
plus years
right turned red and it was a political
bloodbath
so michael moore was wrong he thought he
was correct when he said they'd go in
there and send
the deputy to the establishment but if
we follow the same path as the uk
then we should see a landslide the polls
were wrong about brexit the polls were
wrong about the conservative victory
and they were way off they did lean
towards a conservative you know winning
but they thought the conservatives in
the uk wouldn't get enough to actually
have a majority
and they would be stopped by a coalition
party that's how parliament works
and they were wrong it was an over it
was a crushing defeat sending shock
waves
through europe even and then brexit
happened boom a month later
brexit is done it's going to be a
transitional period
if we follow suit the polls are wrong
the politicos are wrong
and we might see another one of these
epic landslides red wave
more than that like a 49 state landslide
yeah
so here's my theory which i mentioned
the other day
when times are good people don't get
active
they the silent majority hangs out and
says i don't care about politics like
that like that comic where the guy's in
the guillotine he says i don't really
care for politics
but what happens when you have four
years of absolute psychosis
and then the last year 2020 is the worst
it's ever been
and it's not trump's fault trump gave
you the best economy of your lives
yep but all of a sudden now they look
it's one thing if russiagate was true
then people would be like wow
trump did wrong instead the democrats
were wrong
not only were they wrong they're the
ones who caused it
they're the ones who started it
illegally
yeah trying to basically a coup on on a
sitting president
they were wrong and so everybody said
all that for what
they were wrong about jesse simolet they
were wrong about covington they were
wrong about ukraine gate impeachment
failed
and at this point i don't there's
probably some people who blame trump but
i imagine there's a lot of people saying
the democrats need to
stop yeah just stop well now they're
trying to blame
kovit on trump it's like how he he's
locked down and you
the democrats ridiculed him for locking
down
when he did he tried to to help
mandate everything and they're like you
can't tell us what to do we're gonna go
walk around in chinatown pelosi
walk around in chinatown everything's
great everybody like
no and i can't believe trump is gonna
lock everything down now she's calling
it the trump virus
get out of here pelosi i can't wait for
you to be voted out
you factor this in with the fact that
there were mass riots jake jake ball
getting uh getting rated you know famous
youtuber getting ready for this
and then you see the governors of your
state marching with these people
what do you think a regular person is
going to be thinking when they're listen
listen man i've heard stories about
what's going on for people who've lost
their jobs and
and it's terrifying it terrifies me i
mean scares me some of these stories
break my heart
i was reading a story about one guy who
you know lived with his girlfriend
and they lost their jobs because they
worked in the service industry their
savings dried up
and now they're just throwing away all
their furniture because they have
nowhere to go and they have to move
they can't afford moving companies and
they're getting out of the cities
and i'm like that's a nightmare for a
lot of people some of them probably
blame trump
but the ones who've been paying
attention are look
people don't understand at the national
level these politicos is what i'm
talking about they have no idea what
they're talking about
because they live in dc they assume that
the federal government is literally
everything
but they don't understand when i when i
watch cable tv here in south jersey
i get commercials for local news local
news is what comes on
after watching certain shows and the
local news talks about the governor of
pennsylvania in new jersey
not donald trump and i'm not hearing
from local outlets and local papers
and people i live next to who are saying
man did you see what donald trump did no
they're saying do you see what murphy
did
yeah they're talking about the democrats
so these i
imagine you're like these politicos in
dc don't understand
that at a local level people actually
pay attention to their council people
are who they're i mean look in seattle
they're calling into the council
meetings complaining about the radical
experiment
of defunding the police they're not
calling trump they're not blaming trump
for that
this is what i think these dc people
don't get they all follow each other
they see the news about the federal
government scotus congress and trump and
they think that's all anyone cares about
yeah because those the all the
mainstream media
have all the connections to the money
you know the establishment they all are
are connected
in their own little bubble and they're
like tell all the news
to push out this narrative because we
need the people to believe this
and then they're doing that and other
people are like sorry we don't listen to
that anymore
we we realize that that's bs so we're
not we're not going to fall prey to that
well i think it's for waking up i think
it's less nefarious than that the study
that was citing before found
that in cable tv okay fox msnbc and cnn
all these producers they still talk to
each other on twitter
so they share the same guests and even
though they claim like fox news is fake
news but emma says the msnbc is better
than the
and then other people are no msnbc is
fox news at the at the professional
level these people are all talking to
each other
so it's not uh malicious it's ignorance
it's it's they're in bubbles yeah they
are in isolated bubbles
man it's really crazy look when i
started twitter i
curated some activists some conservative
outlets
and some mainstream outlets and some
leftist outlets
these people when they get on twitter is
they immediately follow their friends
so the only things they see on twitter
what they think is real life are the
things their friends are talking about
good point then because all their
friends are complaining about trump they
don't realize regular people in
pennsylvania
dude i was i was in pa and i was talking
i can't remember who i was talking to
but they did not care about trump they
were talking about i don't know who the
governor of
pa is who's the governor of pa is it
wolf wolf i think yeah they were like
can you believe what this guy's doing
and i was like what's he doing and
they're like oh dude it's been a
disaster
he's out marching with these people
right and i was like interesting what do
you think about trump and they're like
uh what's trump doing he's not
like i live in pa you know right people
don't get it man yeah it's interesting
some of my uh
some of my former facebook friends that
were reaming me out for
saying i'm gonna vote for trump went
ahead and
also complained about gavin newsom a lot
like they were
ripping him apart and i'm like how are
you
like do you realize what trump's doing
is trying to help you
and gavin newsom is trying to sell out
your state but it's not even about that
right
i'm i'm saying you can absolutely hate
trump
yeah but do you think they're gonna vote
for gavin ism again no
exactly exactly absolutely now i still
think they'll vote democrat
they'll just primary him from someone
further left and the downward spiral
continues
right but this is the point i'm making
that ev the people who
even the people who hate trump there's
going to be a reaction against
the local level democrats wow like evan
newsom
so it's that's why i think what we might
see is akin to the uk
not because trump is going to you know
you know landslide everything but
because we're going to see something
really interesting
shift so we we recently learned that
progressives
a couple progressives just beat uh in
their primaries they beat the incumbent
democrats yeah
and that is a part of it i saw that
they're getting they're they're
they're angry about what the democrats
are doing and they're voting for change
but the only direction they know to go
is the left because you know the right
is evil i suppose
i do think however the suburbs are not
going to view it that way
and they're going to be like trump so
trump will probably landslide
we'll see though man you know cheating
is a factor melon vote failure's a
factor
25 of the ballot in brooklyn being
disqualified is a factor
so who knows what's going to happen i
genuinely believed
that trump would not win in 2016 not
because he didn't have the support
but because they wouldn't let him win
either through
you know dirty games or hard
manipulation of the vote
yeah like i've known about vote hack
vote vote box
hacking for a long time some some like
teenager at a hacking convention hacked
a voting box a digital voting you know
voting booth yeah remember that in like
a couple hours
or something right so it's like dude i'm
not confident at all
and then it turns out they actually did
cheat they colluded with other
establishment
organizations like cnn giving the
questions to hillary so they could try
and stop bernie sanders and try and stop
trump but they weren't enough yeah
too many people were addicted to trump
well now they made ballot harvesting
legal in california i think and in in
nevada they're trying it also
so we'll see we'll see how that plays
out yeah the media they definitely have
allies in media who will try and stop
anyone having these conversations
but yeah yeah look in 2018
i was thinking about this i'm like i
said that i thought the republicans were
going to sweep
yeah and then early on the initial
reporting was that republicans for the
most part did
but then they started saying oh oh found
some belts oh
oh well found some more ballots oh
here's some here's some i found him in
biden's basement they started finding
ballots all over the place
and then all sudden all these democrats
ended up winning and then there was the
blue wave
yeah and i was like that's weird sketchy
early on i was very much just like well
wow you know the mailing ballot said
didn't expect that
should have waited now we're at this
point where we're seeing all these votes
get disqualified and i'm like
could it be that you have corrupt people
not i'm not talking about some like
grand conspiracy where hillary's got
puppet strings i'm talking about you get
one dude
who's got trump derangement syndrome and
he looks at a ballot
and he can see it's republican and he
goes this this this one's
i don't think the signature is right
they throw in the garbage or what
happens if
one post you know post office worker
sees a big box
and it's from a republican heavy
republican district yeah and he just
looks around and he kicks it under a
desk hey you know what's really funny
what so i saw a stat i didn't have a
chance to check it but i read something
like
76 percent of postal workers are
actually republicans
so if you don't want the you know the
election to be rigged in favor of the
republicans you should probably just not
do mail-in voting
i just think ultimately we we're not
prepared for mail in voting well we're
not
and it's going to be i mean if the masks
work and we could go shopping at walmart
why can't we go
stamp a freaking thing doesn't make any
sense
voting is more essential than anything
else in this country 100 agree with you
yeah
absolutely i mean maybe if you're like
bleeding to death we can rush you to the
hospital you got to wear a mask
if we if we got certain members of our
government that are selling out our
country
it's awfully important to me yeah and
that's what that's what it seems like
what's happening
this is the big question man how big is
a silent majority how active are they
yeah and are they going to crawl over
broken glass to make sure trump wins
because every every obstacle is being
thrown in everyone's path it's just make
it's emboldening everyone
everyone's going bring it on democrats
we don't care at least that's me i i
like to only speak for myself you know
because but i do
see i see it out there but i know i'm
gonna go out there and i will walk over
class
to vote absolutely somebody somebody i
know posted a meme
from the biden campaign about all of the
bad things trump has done
and like all the problems a meme yeah of
course
of course so i went through it i went
through it point by point yeah
breaking everything down and basically
fact checking all of these
nonsensical claims first of all they
said you know the covet deaths and i was
like well
tenth amendment right trump doesn't have
the authority to go to the states and
dictate what they can do or can't do
during a pandemic
so can you really blame him especially
with cuomo right and he tried to help
also right
i posted the link to andrew cuomo from
propublica saying he was responsible for
6 500 deaths
by putting sick people then there was
one about unemployment and i'm like
trump didn't make covet happen the
democrats are the ones who locked down
their states and shut the economy down
yep
trump was opposed to that and said open
things back up yeah
so you can't blame him for this and i go
through this and i'm like
i respond to each and every every point
and the response i get was a nonsensical
meme just another meme reaction face
just like a
some sort of anti maga no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no that's what i see
it was a general reaction meme oh okay
just of like
you know and i'm like i just broke all
this down for you all these lies from
biden's campaign about what's going on
yep
the only there was only one thing on the
list that i was like yep and it was
the uh the inflation of the national
debt and i was like yup
trump was said he was gonna knock it
down he's gonna it was gonna go down
and it's certainly gone way way up yeah
that makes me so mad that the national
idea yeah well now things are getting
scary when it comes to the economics man
well i mean but at the same time he's
going after big tech companies
with that have this multinational
not paying taxes kind of you know
working the system
to get out of the way and he's going
after those people
maybe that will help bring our deficit
down quite a bit we need
in my opinion we need manufacturing back
absolutely 100
we need to help the people here get jobs
because that the competition and labor
market will allow people to get better
wages
we want the pressure to be on the
business owners not on the job seekers
yeah the job seekers should be excited
that there's always a new job around the
corner yeah
and they can and these businesses are
fighting to get the best talent
well you know what you know what there's
going to be a good future in
a couple things glass because all these
glass
of every company has been i mean it's
funny
but and it's sad but it's true hold on
hold on can you explain
why well the rioters have been breaking
glass everywhere
i mean everyone knows this yeah now now
concrete
no joke concrete you know and learning
maybe
like what's going to be the advances of
concrete our our
infrastructure is is needs a rehaul
our dams there's over 3000
dams that that provide energy for our
country
like we talk you know about three gorges
dam right now and
and what's going on there they built
that and finished it in 2008
and it's it's already about it's could
be crumbling like right now
right so it's only 12 years old right
and and the dams in our country
have have been around average is about
50 years old
okay and with a shelf life of 57 years
so in the next seven years a lot of our
our energy uh structures the dams are
gonna
need to be rehabbed yeah so there's
gonna be a boost
you you know we're gonna have to take
care of that or else our energy is going
to go away
so concrete you know learning how to
construction
trade electricity heating and air
conditioning if you talk about uh
you know global warming what's up boku
and uh
you know we're gonna need all the trade
is a huge thing
i'm just you know i'm just giving a
little tips for people who are looking
for what what to work for and it's like
that's those are all things that are
gonna be needed thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch
the full show tune in to this channel
subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode